uh let's see
crowder's back and he had a special
guest today oh
boy bellam uh one morning and i was
surprised how everything was boarded up
i was very surprised when we came down
here in 6th street for people if we can
see everything going on
everything is boarded up and you have
all the black lives matter and
stuff sprayed over it right right and if
you try and paint over that if a
business owner does they can actually be
charged with a hate crime in some cases
it can be actually criminal
to wash your own wall that's right now
the
financed communist anti-american
propaganda
on your property on your boarded up
business alex is eating again huh
he's eaten i think everybody's gained
some corn yeah of course
i think alex is among them uh is a
civil right and if you paint over it you
get charged with hate crime yeah well
there was a business owner who will
remain nameless in dallas who was like i
just cleaned that
and then he just ended up having to
leave it up you know one guy who we
interviewed yesterday when we were doing
the change of mind
said these boards were up for so can you
tell me is it
or is it more so the rioting and
breaking the windows it was both
when it started really six months ago
here some of the big corporations
boarded up because they were on the
inside baseball that this was going to
be a
permanent shutdown until trump was
driven from office but the smaller
businesses tried to stay open but then
the city ordered them closed but they
didn't board up but billions
yeah that makes sense it's really hard
to find some of these numbers for
example
you know my home state of michigan right
they were going to release the
am i wrong am i wrong for thinking they
should have gotten a dolly
this would have made a great dolly shot
yeah scorsese film you know when they do
the whole walk down the street they do
like one big shot
nursing home deaths what were i think
the number of one point they said it was
close to 40 percent
40 something odd percent of uh all
coveted deaths were nursing home deaths
then they just stopped counting them you
can't find the updated new york's doing
the same thing
yeah yeah and we couldn't get them in
michigan governor whitmer kind of
started and never finished
absolutely this is this is startling i
mean i we talked about it with deep
outside alex isn't fat he's just short
for his ideal weight
like war eagle says jones used the term
inside baseball 12 times per hour now
he really does um this is really a
post-apocalyptic
types
there's a lot of stuff that's
post-apocalyptic and some stuff that
we've seen
this doesn't look that post-apocalyptic
at least where they're walking down
right now
yeah particularly if if they're drawing
the murals on these boards that are
going to get taken down eventually who
gives them i'm not saying it's not
annoying and i'm not saying the business
owner stuff isn't [ __ ] up because it
is of course it is
but i wouldn't call this fallout but
it's it's yeah exactly i i
i'm more concerned with the guys getting
pulled out of trucks and kicked in the
head
that's i'd like to nip that in the bud
before the
murals doesn't really george
and you all on the back of us of this
sad guy who was just totally drugged out
yeah and don't worry we're not talking
about you
we're just talking about the guy in the
picture
am i wrong stephen but i'm starting to
think these are getting pretty uppity
jesus christ that's fine it's like
[ __ ] final form
he can't be here alex he's drug addicts
yeah but then they become this symbol
that the police
who basically are janitors for them now
they clean up their crap they take them
to the hospital and now when something
gets out of hand and there's a mistake
and something happens
the police get charged with murder right
yeah it is uh did you watch the full
body cam footage
it's very sad it was very sad and i
think what's going to happen
unfortunately you're going to see more
backlash because
listen it's a tragedy we always said it
was an example of
imp alex jones starting to walk like
hank hill's dad
i think alex is just turning in to his
dad
cotton hill cotton hill
uh apparently somebody said that
alex jones went after bill burr did he
yeah here's a few minutes though of bill
burr the comedian
up there saying let's depopulate people
on this netflix special
here it is take over exactly where it's
leading and what they're going to do to
you and your family
and they're coming they're going to
shoot you up and you're never going to
have kids again you're going to get
cancer and die
and they're going to have liability
protection and bill gates is going to
laugh about it i've been spending a lot
of time
on event 201 and lockstep where
the rockefeller foundation of the
melinda gates foundation
admit they're bringing in world
government authoritarianism the end of
an open free society now i think bill
burr is a good comedian he's against
cancer culture
and he's got courage to come out and
criticize it in this landscape of
cowards i mean in a world of cowards
a person with any courage is a hero and
that's a scary thing
and when the people fear the government
there is tyranny when the government
fears the people there is liberty as
thomas jefferson said but he did this
whole special
on netflix and he got into depopulation
and he said let's just say what we want
we need to depopulate the earth some
areas are overpopulated some places have
taken up the resources but
most areas are not and and you could
sustain this population
if you remove having 2.1
replacement rate for every two adults
two point he was
he was joking i think i remember the
whole joke was sink a cruise ship
it was a bit and i don't think billboard
actually wants to sink cruise ships
and also you know stanhope's done bits
like that before a lot of people have
done bits about that
even people discussing it um
seriously i'm all for some depopulation
if it's not
done in an insidious fashion
you know what i mean like there's ways
to educate people and
and to to you know what i mean to
prevent people from going too
you know birth control you know not not
saying abortion but actual birth control
and stuff like that
um but the idea
that we would pollute a little less and
probably
not eat through resources as badly um
it's it's not that that out there of an
idea that we shouldn't be
if we're we were like three billion i
think
at the turn of the 20th century
something like that 34 billion
and we've like doubled that and then
what if we double it again and we're at
14 billion
in 100 like that's yeah there's nothing
wrong with saying that that's
unsustainable
which is you know the entire discussion
that we have all the time about getting
off of planet earth
and going to another place is based on
the fact that we know that we can't
sustain this growth
i don't see a problem there well
i think what i take from this is like
he's he's just kidding it's a stand-up i
know he's just kidding but
but it's like this is kind of hysterical
he's tying a billboard thing and
he's working with bill gates and he's
gonna shoot you up and give you cancer
you gotta have kids and you're like
billboards just doing the whole i think
we should kill everybody but what do i
know it's the same thing he's always
done
same gimmick i don't think gilbert has
ever stood up and said i'm an expert on
things bridge
society collapses unless you get rid of
a human future
and that's what's happening right now is
a globalist reclamation project
to sabotage civilization they opened up
as fest
globalist reclamation project
buckethead's in the band oh
nice yeah and destroy the real carrying
capacity of the earth
have those that implement the crisis
rioting as the planetary rulers and the
saviors
here's what the comedian has so they're
all sitting there you know that was
just out six months ago and now they're
not allowed to go to hear another human
talk because the clamp down's here oh
you're like yay kill everybody oh well
we're starting it
we're making you obsolete right now
getting rid of the infrastructure for
you worldwide depression hundreds of
millions are going to starve to death
and we're using billboard to normalize
it
it's a little bit of a stretch alex
always watching f is for family
all right but don't worry you're getting
free checks that first six months that
first year
some of you are the middle class is not
the poor people
oh no they're all having to move in with
mama but mama don't have money no more
so
oh there's gonna be more homeless oh the
collapse is here
and so a sick part of me is all these 60
some millions
of babies we've killed nobody came to
their help so
all these yuppies and trinities want to
live in the dystopic new world order and
get exterminated well line on up
somebody to chat says burr isn't funny
burri is funny i mean look you might not
like a lot
of this political stuff now i think
burst funny
also alex dystopian it's pronounced
dystopian
uh right let's see here
somebody in the chat said that alex
jones looks like a gigantic [ __ ]
wrestler
full-size major wrestler